let's talk now to the professor of
theoretical epidemiology at the
university of oxford
uh sumatra gupta uh welcome to the show
professor
i'm looking at the seven day moving
average of new cases
uh it's now six thousand two hundred and
twenty
a week ago it was four thousand five
hundred and one
so it's not doubling it's rising by
under forty percent
in spain and france daily cases higher
than they are in britain
but they're flattening at around twelve
thousand uh there was no
movement in france in the past week on
daily cases and in spain there was a
slight drop
i would suggest to you but you know so
much more than i do than this
that it's inconceivable that we will get
to 50 000 cases a day
as professor whitty has said within two
weeks
inconceivable am i wrong um i would tend
to agree with you
i mean what we have here are a set of
scenarios
and what we ought to be thinking about
is
what is probable what's possible what's
unlikely
and the only way we can do that is by
understanding the logic behind
these projections or whatever they're
called
not predictions apparently so you know
you look at that
someone stands up and says it's doubling
and
if it doubles in this way then
you know just do the math or do the math
and you'll get to these extraordinary
numbers
and you know if you get stuck in the oh
yeah true if you do the math
it does go that way then you miss out on
that vital component which is
why would it do that in the first place
and so if you start to think about why
would it do that
then you realize that that sort of
thinking
you know if there is any logic to it at
all it
applies to an epidemic that's just
taking off
where everyone's susceptible and ready
available for infection and as far as we
know that is
not the case in um
many of these countries certainly not in
the uk
so that's the first thing to note now we
don't know
exactly how many people are at the
moment
immune or not available for infection
because we thought we'd be able to find
this out by doing these
antibody tests but as it turns out the
situation
is a bit more complicated than that so
the serum positivity in other words how
many people have antibodies
is not a very good indication of how
many people are immune
so given that and given the
extraordinary or
quite wide heterogeneity in numbers
who have antibodies or proportions who
have antibodies
it's quite difficult to make firm
predictions
about where we're going but at the
moment
what we're seeing is not is very much in
line
with what happens to any other infection
like the coded
around this time of the year in other
words everything goes up
flu goes up uh pneumococcal pneumonia
goes up
there are a thousand people a week dying
of
flu and pneumonia at the moment so these
so the context is very important as is
an understanding a very basic
understanding of the dynamics
of these infections well you mentioned
that number dying of flu the seven day
moving average from
covert deaths is 40 at the moment which
is a lot less
but easy to to someone like me who can
do the arithmetic
that is has no medical expertise
whatsoever
i would come to the conclusion that we
were sort of false prospectus
intentionally
these figures were put to us with the
scientists being complicit
and the politicians suffering up the
ground for new lockdown measures
what would be wrong with that conclusion
well it's not
for me to say what the intention of the
scientists or
the politicians um what they are
all i can say is that i think they
should think very very carefully
about the costs of lockdown and it's not
just i think we should get away from
just talking about the economy because
people tend to separate
the economy from the impact on lives
so the economy is not just this sort of
external thing
that we have to attend to and which we
can
sort of ignore and and continue down
this kind of
narrow track of trying to keep covid
under control
what happens as we try to do that to
other public health issues and the
economy
insofar as that affects the lives
and we're talking about life and death
we're talking particularly if we
start to broaden our perspective from
outside the uk
to the world which is i think as
international
citizens we should do we're talking
about people dying of hunger
so the economy is not sort of this
external thing that we don't need to
worry about
um it's about lives against lives and i
think
that's something that's completely or
it's not obvious
in the conversations around the control
of this
virus that have been occurring since the
very beginning the policy response
when the pandemic started to take off
was locked down
uh and many people thought at the time
we don't really know what's going to
happen it's a mystery
it's uncharted territory it's probably
the right thing to do that was the
public opinion but here we are now six
months in
september and the policy response to
rising cases
is still various varieties of lockdown
is that the right policy response i
don't think so
i think lockdown simply delays
things it doesn't solve the problem at
all it just delays it
and as you say right in march maybe you
know you could make the case
that we needed to buy some time so you
know let's go into the lockdown
uh we can afford maybe a month of
lockdown
why not do that maybe you know that a
case could be made for that
although personally i was worried right
at the outset about the effects of
lockdown but you know
i think one could make a case for it uh
particularly given the sort of worst
case scenario that the imperial
college model had had presented um
but it is very clear you don't have to
have a very
uh you know sophisticated understanding
of the dynamics
of this disease um that
to to appreciate that locking things
down can only delay it
delay its course so and if
that were if it would possible do that
without any other costs
then sure carry on locking down but it's
patently obvious that you cannot do that
that there are profound
costs and there these costs are just
mounting
so sorry that's fine
what did you make of a cake pointing
the public opinion was perhaps moving in
a direction that
maybe we now need just to learn to live
with this
not that it means uh everything back to
normal or anything like that
but that we've got to accept is going to
be around for some time
and rather than lockdowns or extreme
measures we should learn
to live with it would that be a
sensible response i think that's a very
sensible response and that's what
should have been made available to the
as an option or as the
most likely course um again
right from the outset because that is
what it was likely to happen
with a virus of this ilk
so what's most likely to happen and
desirable is that it settles down to
what we call an
endemic equilibrium such as we enjoy
with influenza with pneumococcal
the bugs that cause pneumonia and a
variety of other
pathogens we live at an
endemic equilibrium with them and live
lives normally and accept
the deaths that they cause because you
know that's what society is about
it's about optimizing on this really
quite
complex landscape of risks and
um weighing the costs and benefits to
arrive
at a solution that is the best thing
for everybody when you uh put these
points to the prime minister
what did he say uh
nothing but then he has responded since
then
no clearly he didn't listen to you did
he he has
since then uh responded in in terms that
suggest he
doesn't agree with what we propose as a
strategy
which is that we allow the virus to
reach that endemic equilibrium
but meanwhile you know try and hasten
that
moment where it becomes the same as
flu which may have already happened we
don't know but
um to try and get there the best thing
to do is to allow it to circulate
and protect the vulnerable people and
then once it gets reaches that
endemic equilibrium uh life can return
to normal there's it doesn't have to go
to some new normal
we can go back to the old normal maybe
we can learn a few things
from the experiment but
[Music]
foreign